à l'étranger les premières opérations de
neutralisation du gaz toxique de bhopal
se sont bien terminés dans une ville
quasi déserte mais qui commence
doucement à se repeupler jean-claude
darricau bhopal dimanche une ville
fantôme déserté par cinq cent mille
habitants 500 milles sur les 800 mille
que compte la cité dans les hôpitaux 150
malades seulement accepté de rester sur
les 2600 hospitalisé l'annnonce de la
remise en marche de lusine a provoqué
une panique telle que pour endiguer le
flot humain l'armée et la police ont été
sur le pied de guerre pendant trois
jours les forces de l'ordre ont regroupé
une partie des habitants de bhopal dans
neuf camps provisoires à 15 km du centre
tandis que les autres se regrouper dans
les villes voisines à trois heures
trente hier le processus de
transformation du gaz a commencé sous le
contrôle de spécialistes équipés de
masques
toute la nuit des camions-citernes ont
arrosé les rues de la ville l'isocyanate
de méthyle selon les experts se
neutralisant au contact de l'eau en fin
de journée trois des quinze tonnes de
gaz était transformée en pesticides
il faudra donc encore au minimum quatre
jours pour que l'on soit sûr que le gaz
mortel qui a fait on s'en souvient de
1500 morts et près de 200 mille victimes
atteintes de troubles nerveux ou de
cécité soit chimiquement réduit comme
apparemment l'opération transformation
du produit toxique s'est passé sans
incident nouveau quelques réfugiés par
est amorcé un timide retour
une chose est certaine la yunnan carbide
a décidé de cesser définitivement sa
production de gaz à bhopal